[Musica]
sono nato nel giugno del
1972 in un comune del Trevigiano negli
anni 80 che per me sarebbero stati gli
anni della scelta lavorativa dalle mie
parti investire legati all'agricoltura
erano snobbati dai ragazzi
i contadini erano derisi come se
lavorare la terra fosse meno degno meno
nobile di un qualunque altro lavoro e
quindi io
pur arrivando da due famiglie contadine
da generazioni scelgo un'altra strada
un pezzo di vita passato per i campi dei
nonni a cogliere da piante da ortaggi
quello che quella stagione mi offriva o
a godere tantissimo nell'immergere i
piedi nudi nel fango di una pozzanghera
creata da un tubo dell'irrigazione che
accidentalmente perdeva io non so se
siamo stati quei lunghi momenti a
contatto con la natura con la terra
creare dentro di me quell'intimità e
quel rispetto Per l'elemento terra o
l'apprendere con l'arrivo dell'età
adulta che anche in tante altre parti
del mondo chi Coltiva la terra è
deriso sfruttato spesse volte anche
oppresso Fatto sta che a 40 anni
Sento forte questo richiamo e faccio
ritorno alla terra nel 2014 Infatti
fondo col mio migliore amico e socio
Forever bambù Con lo scopo di creare
Foreste di bambù gigante in Italia
partendo da terreni abbandonati ne
esistono 4 milioni di ettari in Italia o
da terreni esausti dall'agricoltura
industriale quel tipo di agricoltura o
quell'accezione di metodo agricolo in
grado di
rovinare eliminando la sostanza organica
del terreno tutto per noi è partito
dalla terra dal desiderio di
ripristinare qualche cosa l'integrità
che da qualche d'un altro era stata
rovinata
a 40 anni e con la nascita delle nostre
figlie abbia sentito nascere dentro
forte il
desiderio forse più la necessità di fare
qualcosa che incidesse nelle nostre vite
di padri ci siamo sentiti responsabili
per loro di migliorare questo angolo di
mondo che è l'Italia
durante questi nove anni di vita nel
quale abbiamo realizzato due milioni e
mezzo di metri quadrati di foreste
questa attività mi ha fortemente
lavorato dentro facendomi incontrare
scontrare col mondo agricolo con quello
scientifico con quello industriale
l'ultimo motivo di queste accese
interazioni è il Bios cognitivo
evidenziato da Harvey lock A proposito
della sostenibilità
ad oggi l'immagine più utilizzata per
esprimere questo concetto è quella che
vedete alle mie spalle tre cerchi che si
intersecano i tre cerchi rappresentano
l'ambiente E con esso la terra la natura
poi c'è la società e poi c'è l'economia
come a dire che questi tre cerchi sono
rappresentanti di tre ambiti equivalenti
per importanza ma non lo sono
tutti noi ciascuno di noi
fondamentalmente per Vivere ha necessità
di cibo di acqua di aria
ha bisogno della terra non di strutture
economiche e sociali badate bene che sto
parlando di necessità
Quindi perché se evidentemente
l'ambiente è sovrastruttuale rispetto a
società ed economia poi non è stato così
rappresentato
perché quando hanno definito quello
schema A quel tavolo non erano presenti
e non hanno chiesto a
api Merli lupi coralli batteri Cedri del
Libano alle migliaia di specie che noi
abbiamo fatto scomparire sul pianeta
cosa ne pensassero A quel tavolo c'erano
solo uomini e Finanza
a causa Però di questo fraintendimento
di questo equivoco di questa perdita di
contatto con la realtà stiamo mettendo a
repentaglio la vita delle generazioni
future su questo pianeta perché
consideriamo tutto sullo stesso piano
mentre non è tutto sullo stesso piano la
terra che ci ospita che ci dà da vivere
la terra viene tecnicamente
scientificamente ed economicamente prima
Eh ma quindi vuoi che andiamo a fare
tutti i contadini tutti i boscaioli
torniamo a vivere nelle caverne no Non
dico questo dico però che possiamo
impegnarci a chiederci se le scelte che
compiamo rispecchino questa gerarchia le
scelte come singoli come aziende E come
espressione del mondo pubblico
e se ci facciamo delle domande poi ci
diamo delle risposte e poi prendiamo
coraggio ed agiamo di conseguenza
per tutti prima viene l'ambiente la
natura il pianeta poi viene la società
poi viene l'economia
lo dico a quelli un po' più resistenti
quelli che fanno il mio mestiere gli
imprenditori i manager ma anche a
vantaggio che degli altri prima viene
l'ambiente la natura la terra Poi la
società poi l'economia
dal 2014 anche noi ci siamo interrogati
e abbiamo deciso con non poche
difficoltà esitazioni la cultura che noi
facciamo era inesistente in Italia di
coltivare con metodi naturali metodi che
rispettassero il luogo fin da subito Io
ho cercato di far passare un canone in
tutti i miei soci Oggi ne ho 1650
All'epoca erano solo 7 quando ho
cominciato questo canone recita così
lascia un luogo meglio di come lo hai
trovato
Oggi tra i tanti metodi abbiamo scelto e
sviluppato il metodo simbiotico e
coltiviamo agricoltura simbiotica
l'agricoltura simbiotica è in grado di
ripristinare l'integrità e la vitalità
dei suoli vitalità ai minimi storici lo
fa Grazie l'utilizzo di consorzi
microbici di micorrize di zeoliti e di
humus la microbiologia dei suoli è una
scienza ancora altamente sperimentale
Noi pensiamo di saper tutto ma sappiamo
poco poco eh sotto dei piedi sotto i
nostri piedi si dirà che abbiamo un
pianeta ancora del tutto sconosciuto ma
ciò che si è conosciuto è che esiste una
Simbiosi esiste una vita comunicativa e
di mutualità
forse cose che gli esseri umani
dovrebbero un po' riconquistare che
riguarda tutti gli esseri del sottosuolo
una fitta internet ed Intranet che mette
in collegamento piante insetti batteri
microrganismi funghi
e animali di Maggiore dimensione
l'agricoltura simbiotica riesce a
ripristinare questa rete invisibile
portando risultati concreti come
l'aumento della sostanza organica ma
anche la forza il benessere delle piante
e la durata e la qualità di frutti
ortaggi una volta raccolti e quindi
qualità per tutti gli esseri che se ne
cibano
l'agricoltura simbiotica ha la capacità
di riportare la vera biodiversità fatta
di miliardi e miliardi di esseri che
popolano il sottosuolo e che ci
garantiscono
garantiscono a piante animali e ad
esseri umani la salute anche se non li
vediamo ci sono
e dipendiamo da loro
i motivi per cui noi reagiamo foreste
sono diversi
il primo avete capito ripristinare il
lo stato naturale dei luoghi l'integrità
dei luoghi realizzandoci sopra Qualcosa
di davvero bello e fruibile da tutti se
non avete mai passeggiato in una foresta
di bambù gigante non serve che andate in
Giappone venite nelle nostre qui in
Italia
noi tra l'altro non utilizzando
pesticidi non utilizzando diserbanti
spesso ci troviamo a passeggiare assieme
con Lepri Eccolo qua
assieme con fagiani con libellule con
farfalle E picchi che fanno il nido
nelle canne più grosse il secondo
produrre tanta Fibra dalle nostre
foreste per
ripristinare mercati e filiere che un
tempo erano qui in Italia presenti e
sono scomparsi come la produzione della
carta o la produzione del tessuto
oppure iniziare i mercati completamente
nuovi Noi siamo fortemente impegnati con
il digma della Sapienza di Roma nel
produrre
bioplastiche pensate una plastica 100%
made in bambù 100% made in Italy 100%
organica 100% riciclabile una plastica
che non ha visto traccia di petrolio
il terzo motivo
realizzare il mercato italiano del
carbonio nel quale il bambù gioca un
ruolo da campione dell'assorbimento
della CO2
il bambù questa capacità fuori scala
perché non è un albero Ma è una
graminacea un bambuseto è molto più
simile ad un prato che non ad un bosco e
una canna di bambù più simile a un filo
d'erba che non ad un albero e quindi
come l'erba del prato tu la tagli e lei
cresce tu la tagli e lei cresce
i germogli di bambù fanno uguale a
primavera i germogli adulti nel primo
metro crescono tra i 5 e i 7 cm al
giorno ma da lì e fino ai 15 metri
crescono dai 27 ai 45 centimetri al
giorno il germoglio fa 15 metri in tre
mesi
e facendo questa esplosione assorbono
tanta CO2 dell'atmosfera un bambuseto
assorbe 36 volte la CO2 rispetto ad un
bosco tradizionale nel fare questo
mestiere è un campione
lui assorbe più CO2 di quella che noi
emettiamo nel coltivarlo e una volta che
questa quantità è stata in surplus è
stata certificata come abbiamo fatto noi
può essere ceduta alle aziende che
emettono In Italia tutte le aziende ma
anche tutti noi esseri umani Anche oggi
è pieno di CO2 purtroppo
E mettiamo in Italia e possono le
aziende compensare in Italia finalmente
conseguendo l'obiettivo di essere Carbon
neutral spesso e volentieri le aziende
nostre clienti Hanno l'azienda vicino ai
nostri bambuseti In sostanza pulisci
dove sporchi lasci il luogo meglio di
come lo hai trovato Ve lo ricordate il
canone di prima
Io vi invito tutti lasciamo questo luogo
di oggi che ci ospita questo luogo è un
terreno lasciamolo meglio di come lo
abbiamo trovato
il bambù quindi è il nostro alfiere col
quale noi vogliamo affermare che la
natura l'ambiente la terra sono
prioritari e da essi possiamo trovare
risposte e soluzioni a tutti i danni che
in questi anni abbiamo combinato
Eh ma il bambù è infestante
permettimi amico mio dirti che è la tua
mente ad essere infestata
l'essere umano
è stato in grado di
inquinare
distruggere usurpare
è stato in grado di cementificare di
disboscare è stato in grado di uccidere
è stato in grado di far scomparire
specie sul pianeta far migrare
popolazioni intere
l'essere umano ha prosciugato laghi
millenari
per coltivare il cotone
necessario produrre i blue jeans
e poi sarebbe il bambù ad essere
infestante
la specie più infestante del pianeta
Terra È l'essere umano
il titolo di questo mio intervento è la
ricerca dell'integrità perché
l'integrità è ciò che io inseguo e cerco
nella mia vita ogni giorno
e lavorando con la terra e con i giusti
metodi Io so che anche dove non c'è si
può ripristinare
E se si può ripristinare nella terra
credimi l'integrità si può ripristinare
anche in noi esseri umani Grazie
[Applauso]